new characters diminished screen time
and some very strange plotting the much
hyped ending to blumhouse's Halloween
Trilogy has fans in an uproar Halloween
ends the third and final installment in
director David Gordon Green's Michael
Myers Trilogy has been met with mixed
reviews from fans of the franchise
audiences have been particularly vocal
about the trilogy ending on such an
unexpected and experimental note the
final showdown between Lori Strode and
the series Boogeyman simultaneously hit
theaters and peacock meaning viewers
could stream the bloody Affair from the
comfort of their own homes the variety
of fan responses along with the same day
release model has so far led to a
smaller than projected box office return
according to deadline the film's
predecessor Halloween kills was also met
with divided reactions from fans as
green took the Michael Myers story into
Uncharted Territory kills gorily paid
tribute to John Carpenter's original
1978 movie by depicting the trauma
Michael's original spree had inflicted
on the people of haddenfield for decades
Green's second installment also brought
back multiple characters from the very
first Halloween movie with Halloween
ends green continues his exploration of
how evil can infect and spread while
wrapping up his iteration of the Michael
Myers timeline however many viewers seem
to be disappointed with the film's sharp
subversion of expectations for the
self-proclaimed conclusion the final
trailer for Halloween ends sold the film
as the long-awaited deadly confrontation
between Lori Strode and Michael Myers
while the film eventually makes good on
that promise it takes an unprecedented
approach to get there as a result some
fans were left unfulfilled by the last
Halloween movie we'll see for a while a
lot of the division is centered on new
character Corey Cunningham played by
Rowan Campbell throughout the movie Cory
becomes a vessel for Michael's evil
following a traumatic incident on
Halloween night several years earlier
some thought that Michael's influence on
Corey took away from the highly
anticipated finale with one Twitter user
writing introducing a new character who
adds nothing to the plot in any way into
the final chapter of an iconic film
series is just absurd third he took up
the time which could have gone to more
iconic characters even his demise had
zero impact other fans were critical of
the fact that Michael Myers wasn't given
much screen time and instead became a
minor figure in a movie that was
supposed to be all about him one person
tweeted just saw Halloween ends very
nice of the writers to give Michael
Myers a cameo in his own movie another
viewer took Twitter and pondered I've
never been a huge Halloween franchise
fan but how do you do a Halloween movie
and have Michael Myers is basically a
side character even a Michael Myers
parody account took Umbridge with
Halloween ends and tweeted I can't lie I
was disrespected Michael Myers was the
personification of evil
one thing that everyone seems to be
aligned on though is that Laurie Strode
is just as great as ever even those who
didn't enjoy the latest film were happy
to see Legendary scream Queen Jamie Lee
Curtis back on the big screen again for
instance a vocal critic of Halloween
ends gave Curtis's performance proper
credit tweeting I can say one thing
Jamie Lee Curtis as Lori Strode still
stands as the horror protag nobody comes
close to her at all it's also worth
noting that not everyone hated the final
movie in Green's Trilogy one
particularly proud defender of Halloween
ends tweeted one day Society will admit
how good this is that day might not be
today it might not be tomorrow it might
take a decade but that day will come
another Twitter user agreed tweeting I'm
about to say something so controversial
and yet so brave Halloween ends was
actually good others were much more
receptive to the film's new themes with
one viewer writing Halloween ends was
your ultimate slasher film from the
get-go it was never that type of movie
it's about evil trans ending how people
are monsters about everything this is
the realest Halloween movie showing the
real effect people have on each other
basically it doesn't look like the
debate over Halloween ends is going to
end anytime soon